merci madame reno d'être avec nous et en
direct ce matin sur rtl france
une réouverture des commerces anticiper
pour éviter des cohues c'est ce que vous
voulez c'est ce que vous espérez alors
nous espérons bien sûr l'arrivée nous
avons besoin dans le procès à prendre
donc vous avez besoin de ce quatrième
c'est impératif
on est à la fin du mois clients vous
commencez à faire leurs achats et la fin
du mois c'était un samedi très important
justement en cette fin d'année le
chiffre d'affaires et doit être
primordial pour tous les commerçants
vous êtes justement dans la maroquinerie
combien cela représente-t-il
ce chiffre d'affaires justement pour le
mois de décembre et la fin du mois de
novembre
alors le mois de décembre représente 30%
de notre chiffre d'affaires
donc cette fin d'année est cruciale
nous avons su tous nos stocks de fin
d'année puisque nous comment nous les
passons un an avant donc on n'a rien du
tout on n'a pas anticipé du tout cette
crise sanitaire
donc il va falloir payer tous nos stocks
voire peut-être les vendre aussi à bas
coûts donc nos marges vont être imputée
et avec tout ce qui s'est passé tout ce
printemps je pense qu'on va voir
beaucoup de casse au niveau des
maroquiniers qui serait vraiment
difficile
une des demandes des petits commerçants
étaient
justement de décaler un l'opération du
black friday qui doit normalement se
dérouler le 27 novembre on sait que la
plupart des grandes plateformes
d'internet dont amazon ont décidé voilà
2 2
de faire ça plus tôt le 4 décembre
malgré cela vous vous demandez tout de
même la rouverture dès le 27
est ce que finalement cette opération et
est un petit peu faussé puisque
certaines plateformes ont déjà quand
même a commencé à faire certaines
promotions selon vous oui alors que déjà
nous remercions d'avoir été écoutées sur
ce sujet dont on avait parlé avec le cdf
et à longvic en avait fait la demande
par contre effectivement c'est un petit
peu tardif d'avoir dès qu'elle est
maintenant seulement ce black friday les
grands distributeurs ont déjà commencé
leur black friday j'ai reçu d'une grande
plate-forme des catalogues disant black
friday de 20 à 27
donc voilà par contre effectivement on
pourra peut-être un peu nous décaler et
faire quelques promotions bien que ça
soit pas forcément notre but mais bon on
a été écouté après je crains
malheureusement que ce soit un petit peu
tard et que le black friday soit lancée
de toute manière donc on risque de
tomber ce peut-être peut-être sur une
période de black friday qui va s'étendre
du black friday aux 4 ou 5 décembre
voilà c'est ce que nous redoutons est ce
que le gouvernement était à la hauteur
lors de ce 2ème confinement est ce que
vous avez reçu des aides justement on
sait que le ministre de l'économie avait
assuré beaucoup des deux petits
commerçants pour pas justement être
obligé de mettre la clé sous la porte
alors il ya eu davantage de 7 pour ce
deuxième confinement après il faut que
tout ça se met en place il ya eu des des
propositions aussi sur la digitalisation
là je pense que tout ça va être beaucoup
plus concret bientôt donc oui on a été
davantage aidés on a été écouté par
monsieur grise et je pense qu a fait un
gros travail après nous
dion surtout la l'ouverture après le
reste tu irais qu' on n'est pas des
assistés les commerçants ne touche pas
le chômage ne demande pas être assisté
et non des justes à travailler donc
c'est vraiment le point majeur et ça là
dessus on considère qu'on a été
sacrifiée alors jean castex qui qui a
laissé entendre hier que la réouverture
justement des petits commerces pourrait
se faire au 1er décembre dans un cadre
de protocoles sanitaires bien adapté on
commence déjà un petit peu à s'imaginer
à quoi cela va ressembler puisque une
personne sur huit mètres carrés devra se
trouver à l'intérieur d'une boutique
contre deux personnes auparavant est-ce
que voilà ce dispositif va être possible
à gérer selon vous alors déjà ça va
dépendre de la taille du commerce parce
que vous avez des tout petits commerces
qui pourront mettre peut être un client
donc ça va être vraiment difficile à
gérer au niveau du chiffre
une organisation difficile à mettre en
place
après bien sûr si on est bien conscient
de la crise sanitaire et du faux pas du
tout envenimer les choses
donc tout le monde doit faire un effort
pour mettre tout en place déjà ça a été
fait nous au sein de la maroquinerie
nous avons jamais un guide de bonnes
pratiques en classe depuis le premier
confinement donc bien surtout on va
aller dans ce sens mais c'est vraiment
difficile et bien sûr que le mois de
décembre va être pénalisé bien entendu
sur nos chiffres d'affaires
merci beaucoup en tout cas sophie
bruneau d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes président de
la fédération nationale des détaillants
en maroquinerie et voyages